what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
discussing the most recent developments
in boku no hero including the strong
possibility that the tables
are about to be turned yet again in the
epic battle
against shigaraki in fact the latest
installment of the story
may have just warned us that deku's body
is breaking down from pushing one for
all
too far something that almight may have
been aware of but chose
not to share with deku we've got so much
to discuss
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help
and if you happen to be new to the
channel or you haven't subscribed yet
please subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications that is the only way
to make sure that you will be notified
when we upload a video you can also hit
me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
we're talking about the latest
developments
in the story so please proceed with
caution you have
been warned the action picks up with
deku
floating in the air and using black whip
to keep all the other heroes
airborne right along with him but not
only is deku keeping the other heroes in
the air
he is also using black whip to keep
shigaraki
in the air deku knows that if shigaraki
gets a chance to touch the ground again
he will unleash another horrifying wave
of destruction
and even though deku and the heroes
would be safe because they
are currently in the air the rest of the
city would be in grave danger
so deku decides to try and forcibly keep
shigaraki off the ground
which leads to an incredible airborne
showdown
however we have to remember that deku's
control of black whip and float
is still not perfect he just unlocked
float
moments ago and black whip is still a
relatively new quirk
for him we can't forget that most people
have had their entire lives to perfect
a single quirk but deku is now forced to
juggle multiple new quirks that he
hasn't had a chance to master
and this means that while deku has been
able to stop shigaraki from causing
further damage for the time being
deku's black whip plus float strategy
is by no means perfect even the smallest
mistake from deku at this point in time
could lead to a complete disaster for
everyone involved
after forcing shigaraki into the air
deku releases the heroes and tells them
to take care of gran torino and izawa
who are both in need of immediate
medical attention
endeavour tells shoto to administer
first aid to the wounded
but as all of this is happening
endeavour is extremely frustrated by the
fact that he isn't able to contribute
much to the fight endeavor has already
used up almost all of his firepower
in the previous chapters and he is now
overheating
as the number one pro hero endeavour
feels responsible for protecting
everyone
and he certainly doesn't like the idea
of a student like deku risking his life
while the number one pro hero sits back
and watches
but at this time and under these
circumstances
there isn't much that endeavour can do
at least not yet
he needs to recuperate before he can
start fighting again
and that means that most of the heavy
burden of stopping shigaraki
must fall on deku at least for now as
deku and shigaraki engage in
aerial combat which is pretty awesome i
have to say
shigaraki doesn't seem fazed by the fact
that he was
forced off of the ground by deku in fact
shigaraki mocks
deku he threatens to steal one for all
and since they all like the sky so much
shigaraki vows to send deku and all the
others
straight up to heaven i mean say what
you will about shigaraki but you have to
respect a man who is able to use puns
in such a dire situation however deku
isn't having
any of it he proclaims that he won't
allow shigaraki to keep hurting people
and then he lunges at chigaraki with all
of his might
and then just as these two overpowered
multiple quirk users are about to make
contact
and just as we are all on the edge of
our seats wondering how this battle is
going to unfold
you guessed it it's flashback time
sometime in the recent past all might
gathered a bunch of the class 1a
students to help deku train in order to
master his new powers
this includes bakugo of course but also
ochaco
cerro and tsuyu officially all might
want a deku to improve his control of
black whip
but secretly all might wanted to use the
other students
and ochoko in particular to prepare deku
for mastering nana's quirk float
before it even manifests also this
flashback features deku with an epic fro
since apparently his training sessions
with bakugou and bakugo's constant use
of explosions have affected deku's hair
hey it's not a bad look for deku not bad
at all
so i'm here for it now saro's tape quirk
and i assume tsuyu's tongue-based
abilities
are both helpful for deku in terms of
learning to use and control
black whip but ochako was brought on for
an entirely different purpose
allmight wants her to teach deku to
control his mobility while floating in
midair
the students don't necessarily
understand the significance of this
since they don't know that dekku is
about to unlock yet another quirk
but i actually think that this was a
brilliant idea by all might
ochako's zero gravity quirk can
essentially allow her to mimic the same
conditions that float produces
and so this allows deku to essentially
practice using float
in combination with one for all and
black whip
before he even unlocks the quirk itself
as a result of all might's
big brain move deku is able to practice
keeping his balance and even propelling
himself through the air
using air force so essentially deku is
able to practice using one for all black
weapon float before he even
gets float and this means that when
float does finally manifest
deku will already have some experience
with using all three quirks
at the same time instead of starting
from scratch and learning to use a brand
new quirk in real time
deco will have a solid head start this
one simple idea by all might
likely made the difference between life
and death and that is not
an exaggeration if deku had manifested
float when he did
and he had no prior knowledge of how to
use it even a single moment of
hesitation could have been exploited by
shigeraki
and this could have led to the death of
deku and all the other heroes who are
currently present
this short training flashback actually
adds a lot of valuable context to the
story
and it explains why deku is already able
to use float so effectively on the
battlefield although i'm sure that his
mastery of the new quirk is still
far from perfect and while deku was
undergoing that zero gravity training
all might and bakugou had an interesting
discussion they talked about the
possibility of the other students
finding out about the true nature of one
for all
and they also talked about the
responsibility that comes with having a
great power
but then bakugou said something even
more interesting
bakugou said that in the notebook that
he left about one for all
and all its previous users all might
included detailed descriptions for
all the former users except for the
fourth user
so essentially for many of the previous
users all might include the information
about their quirk
and even some stuff about their lives
like how they died but for some reason
the entry about the fourth user was only
half
finished and if you look at the image it
also appears that
all might scribbled some stuff out
bakugou straight up asks
almight if he found out something about
one for all that he is hiding from deku
almight claims that he hasn't found
anything conclusive and he doesn't want
to speculate about things that he's not
sure of but it is clear that both almaid
and bakugo appear to be worried
about deku and this actually got me
thinking
what is the mystery of the fourth one
for all user
the user who is most likely that guy
with the scar on his face
and could there be some additional
drawbacks to using one for all
that we are still not aware of could it
be that the
fourth user died because of these
drawbacks
and maybe all might has figured that out
and so as not to worry deku
he decided to exclude the way that he
died from the entry
it definitely sounds like there's
something going on with the fourth user
but all might doesn't seem to know
exactly what because if he was sure
i'm sure that he would tell daku at this
point in time
my own personal guess is that the fourth
user may have
died as a result of some unknown
drawback associated with one for all
maybe he pushed his body too far and
pushed one for all to its breaking point
and maybe his body began to break down
just like shigaraki's has been breaking
down
in the last few chapters we can see that
both bakugou and all might are worried
about deku because he never thinks of
himself
and he is always ready to go all out and
risk his own life
for the sake of others if there is some
additional
unknown drawback to using one for all
and deku ends up pushing himself
too hard he could bring about his own
destruction
and that could be what happened to the
fourth one for all
user with how often the tables have been
turning during this
arc it wouldn't surprise me at all if
something like this happens to deku
and this makes him lose his advantage
over shigaraki
with shigaraki's body breaking down and
deku unlocking a new quirk
it definitely seems like deku has the
upper hand at this point in time
but as i said with the way that things
have been going so far in this arc
that could change very quickly at the
end of their conversation
bakugou and all might move on from
talking about deku to talking about
bakugo himself
this part was actually really cool
because bakugo straight up admits that
he used to bully deku because he
couldn't deal with his
own weaknesses bakugo was just
projecting his
own fears and his own lack of confidence
onto deku and bakugo appears to truly
regret that
now and he wants to atone for his
mistakes by helping
deku get stronger this is definitely
some respectable bakugo character
development
so kudos to bakugou for that almight
then goes on to say that the reason why
he had compared bakugou
and endeavour in the past is because
both of them had serious issues with
ego and hubris but both of them are now
undergoing a major change endeavour
couldn't take a good look at himself
until all might was forced to retire and
the responsibility of being the number
one pro hero fell to him
and bakugou couldn't really take a good
look at himself until he saw how hard
deku was working and how committed deku
was to helping others
even at the cost of his own body and his
own
safety so yeah horikoshi is committed to
demonstrating that even deeply flawed
people have the capacity to evolve
and change and endeavor and bakugou are
both examples of this
very thing back in the present as deku
and shigaraki engage in an epic aerial
battle
deku is using 100 of his power to tear
into shigaraki but even though he is
using that much power
shigaraki is still able to adapt to the
100
attacks however it is clear that
shigaraki's wounds are healing slower
than before and the damage is sticking
the super regeneration that chikaraki
uses is no longer being as effective as
it should be
and this means that shigaraki's body is
continuing to break
down but all is not well for deku
either it appears that his last two 100
attacks wrecked his left arm and so
now he must try to strike the final blow
with his right
deck who prepares for an all-out attack
on shigaraki
he is about to literally give it
everything he's got
and as this happens what do you know
deku is thinking that no matter what
happens to him
he must destroy shigaraki at all cost
and then the final pages of the chapter
show deku
landing a massive hit to shigaraki's
midsection
as i said earlier for the moment things
look really good for deku
and they certainly don't look good for
shigaraki but
that could change very quickly this arc
has given us a bunch of such twists and
turns
and i have the feeling that another one
is coming it's no coincidence that right
after we see the flashback of bakugo and
all might and in the flashback they're
worrying about deku because he tends to
go
all out without regard for his own
safety deku straight up confirms that he
will go
all out against shigaraki without regard
for his own personal safety
deku just landed a massive hit on
shigaraki
and it looks like baku and endeavour
down on the ground are preparing to give
deku some additional backup as well
so things are looking pretty good for
the heroes nevertheless
i have a sneaking suspicion that deku is
about to reach
his limit and i believe that his body
may begin to break down in some ways now
that he is using three quirks and going
all out without any regard for his own
safety
there must be a good reason why the
fourth user of one for all was brought
up
in this chapter and why his entry was
only half finished the fact that all
might appears to have scribbled out
parts of it is also very sus
as if he was attempting to hide
something from deku may be trying to
protect
deku from some inconvenient information
as i said earlier my guess is that the
fourth user might have died as a result
of
overusing one for all or some other side
effect that deku doesn't know about
if this were the case or if this is
rumored to have been the case
then perhaps all might scribbled out
that part because he didn't want to
scare deku
until he found out for sure if i'm right
and one for all does have some
additional hidden drawback that deku
doesn't know about
then that drawback is probably going to
kick in right about now
and that will be how the tables between
shigaraki and deku are going to turn
yet again whatever happens this fight is
definitely
not over and i really can't see it
ending before gigantomachia and
dobby and the others arrive at the scene
with dobby in particular
i still believe that he is about to
confront endeavour and shoto
in jakku so even though deku appears to
be wrecking shigaraki
at the moment i don't believe that
shigaraki is about to be defeated at
least not yet
there are more twists and turns to come
in this battle
and it is far from over but let me know
what you guys think what is the real
truth behind the fate of the fourth
one for all user and why was all might
being so
sus about him do you believe that one
for all has a hidden drawback that is
about to affect
deku or do you think that deku might
really win this fight against shigaraki
sooner rather than later finally when do
you think that makia and the other
villains are going to arrive
and what is going to be their actual
contribution to this fight
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero videos right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch it but you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications to make sure that
youtube will actually notify you about
our videos
it's not enough to just click subscribe
you have to go through the trouble of
hitting the bell and then selecting the
option that says
all it's definitely annoying but that's
how youtube works
feel free to hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime opera
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
a very special thank you to alpha sigma
and liam thompson disciples of lord
twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons including
ingrata the world acquired respect
patahifa jonathan king
rathuindeora emperor otaku thomas jones
kin mono
admirath and chris torley finally thank
you also to our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
kings eldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
octor
hinokamian water bonnie parks jason
wilson florian joanne garcia steelers
mcshamus jessica kayla fond deadly saint
and stern hawkins if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you